[Music]
how many of you would consider
yourselves as huggers hmm like you need
a hug oh wait what what like I'm a hug
huggy or hugger mmm no no not like
touches touches an important love
language for you I'm a big hug I like
hugs okay but only from certain people
like me I don't like when just randos
like decide that there's only one I see
like free hugs sign person like when you
just meet somebody and they're already
like hey I'm a closeted hugger we're
like I really I think if I were able to
come out of my shyness
I'd be more like David my dad huggy but
because like I grew up in a different
time period where I'm still kind of
getting used to it after like 20 30
years yeah
that like when someone hugs me I'm like
hey what's up man and then later I'm
like I wish we would have hugged more
you know why I don't want sorb humans I
like kids and dogs oh [ __ ]
you know your energy to get on you
that's what you mean yeah okay yeah I
believe I believe there's some I don't
fact-check my audience and [ __ ] but I
think you're supposed to like if you hug
somebody for like 20 seconds
I'm talking like that's like a meaty hug
like people usually I like that's
[ __ ] you're gonna get a boner first
of all well like if you for real hug
that long where you already mentally
check out of the idea of like like oh is
gonna be done you know when you stop
thinking about when it's over second
hand should give in to yeah there's a
chemical response that your body
actually does whether it's like
oxytocin's or like serotonin or
something that actually releases
therefore doing that I think four or
five times a day yeah 20 plus second
hugs are healthy for you you're supposed
to get four hugs a day minimum yeah so
like when I do
when I do like warm-up warm-ups for my
classes like overseas and stuff like
that oftentimes to just get people going
to beginning of the day with I know
they're gonna teach like or learning
like six routines or whatever we do hug
warm let's just because I know it sounds
so poor gee that sounds dope yeah
how about group war Jia no good boys
yeah and I have people who have it just
another classmate she's like yo you got
hugging around for twenty seconds and
the whole idea is to not think about yet
to not think about another's go thirty
but if I make you not think about you
know the fact that like when it's gonna
be over if you have to get past that you
have to get past that this is awkwardly
long one's gonna be over we're so
trained you set their mind up for it
then they I think they're more receptive
to that and then a second we say swish
and they just move to the next person
you're already warm because you already
you know and the next thing you know the
second people are done with literally
two minutes of hugging they feel exactly
it's like the best thing in the world
that's true I have the reason why even
like your jitters cuz half of it talking
the whole time you're trying to break
someone's arm and hug them are you
breaking my heart forever when you hug
someone does jujitsu cause yours think
all the gable grip so the minute someone
hugs me I can feel their hands to me to
go to a gable grip and oh my god
until they squeeze I because I feel the
aggressive energy during jujitsu so I
feel that too I feel that too but then
when there's like chest to chest
I'm like oh then it goes back that's not
my cat is y'all like wrestle my hand
he'll fight it and then and then once he
gets it he just licks it he's like you
to love it I think my cats the only
living thing that actually hugs for more
than twenty seconds at a time
Oh tips right here and oh we do
it's I hired them then every state 20
[ __ ] seconds though 19 sorry let's go
first you or her huh like if you guys
are hugging right in the kitchen
who's the one I think I usually like go
first because she prevents me for dinner
2 for 20 seconds I feel like you got to
do 20 seconds right now can you explain
why you guys hug okay ready and go get
past the block it hurts a lot because
he's taller too and even like now it's
got a lot of curves how about you Bart
does your neck hurt but it looks like
he's enjoying this I got a good side
since he's a huggie you know I think
after 10 seconds she was like you smoke
that really does happen maybe that's
what a warm-ups need to be instead of
zip zap zop dr. Phil over here no cuz uh
but yeah like that's the reason why I
tend to be the one to break it I'm
shorter my neck is killing my throat and
like I'm just McGregor treatment he does
the from the back and then like wraps
the arms yeah I can do that and that's
like a coat and you're like you can't be
doing one of these though that's like
hella weird oh yeah that's a doggy style
so you go hug yourself
yeah yeah
love oh yeah what if I wonder huggy then
you turn around a challenge from the big
spoon and a nice dog because you can
give a buffoon it's so fun yeah right
it's like I doing this out in public but
this feels good
I hate it so much but I still do it
because I know you like it
I like it thank you you hate it how can
you hate because your head goes into
their back cause like it's like laying
down or long hair and then we're behind
you here's all their foot it a certain
way
thank you but is it the butt a perfect
shape for it for our pelvis though
depends on the butt yeah well we we
can't even spoon though because every
time we spoke because it's spooning is
my [ __ ] favorite we can never spoon
because then he starts humping me I
appreciate that
there you be so sexy what's that not
sitting here I thought you had good
thing though
sure but sometimes sometimes I would
just love to just get hugs and just be
about hugs not [ __ ] move into sex and
then I feel your dick moving behind like
okay that's cool but can we please like
not make it about that right now okay
new role we're taking Anthony's rule
we're doing putting me into this
[Laughter]
I know you're talking about gateway to
boners that's what I'm saying
nikki has been saying that gateway
especially a backwards hug it's all one
down there that's difficult yes but no
boners no boners so how do you get there
you have to okay well you hold are you
upside down so you do a hug and then you
flip her upside down you've all got a
barrel down a hill
so everybody kind of shares the balance
of on top but forgot we had an article
Wow it's okay we talked about it now
your guys's rivalry has gone to Barden
Anthony's a cop the feel and Anthony I'm
a hugger the article here is talking
about how like a lot of people doing
quarantine and this whole pandemic you
know because we have to be at home most
people that live alone they end up
feeling this like skin hunger mm-hmm
like they're actually hungry for touch
and it's a very important thing for a
lot of people and apparently it's
hereditary like a lot of a lot of
Sciences are saying or like this study
here in particular they're saying that
they have found that for women affection
is driven 45% by hereditary factors and
55 from their environments such as
personal experience and the media Wow
the media huh for men seem to solely
rely on their environment
my dad [ __ ] hate hugs and he's a
loser father's day this book so this
he's already way better than before her
before
like I mean you guys man from before old
my dad if he thinks the events over here
he just walked away he never says well
let me I'm [ __ ] like Garden Cafe or
some [ __ ] and we're eating and then he
just starts ordered it goes just gets
the bill and I thought we're still
having a conversation he just starts
walking to the car I'm like oh [ __ ] I
guess the dinners over but nowadays he
came home for Father's Day he'll be like
I'm done yeah I don't go to my dad a hug
and my dad's kind of like like walking
away well I try to put my down on the
spot in front of like friends alright
yeah give me a hug but see that thing I
think that makes a lot of sense for
Asian men because they're like four men
they're mainly driven by their
environment and in the culture as a
whole there's not a lot of physical
touch married so then that's why it gets
passed down to generations that touch is
like it's it's boring which is why he
gets boners right away probably the
biggest lie your parents are so
affectionate they are maybe it's a
generation how your grandpa yeah that's
so funny it's the environment we're
learning it's environment
yeah but when his parents hugged each
other they got boners both of it we
never know we never know it started with
a hug so then if it's fifty persuade
it's all environment - guys what does
that mean yeah so like whatever like
your person like what I was saying
nurture versus nature is right exact the
name good like nurture I like bugs but I
don't feel like [ __ ] need one right
now yeah so people need hug turns out to
be like mainly women who have it in like
their genes like they're just DNA wise
we must have touch because like 45% of
hereditary factors I didn't realise but
my number two love language is touch and
then I know this until I took the love
language quiz I was like oh [ __ ] I think
I really do appreciate you like coddling
we like touching that's what I'm saying
like the cuddling like [ __ ] love
cuddly boo can never cuddle gonna get
caught I mean so much because it goes
straight to all right so like to say
this is it's a sibling hug yeah I didn't
know we're supposed to 20 seconds we're
gonna count okay fine okay we'll just
keep talking he's like in a squat
position we're gonna get close no I am
NOT gonna happen if you don't push the
pelvis together
hey they're minimizing the experience
equivalent to 3 seconds anywhere Steve's
at home watching his vehicle normally
hugs he goes like this yeah it's good
like I hug my family I do it it's not
something I'm like ashamed of I just
don't [ __ ] you know he wouldn't even
make eye contact with people like it was
very difficult so I'm really proud of
you you've grown a lot you actually do
like hug a lot like my brother right
yeah because it's not you know there's
always some kind of weirdness when
there's like co-ed hugging because Altru
I think if you have that in your head
yeah no I get I go he's saying cuz like
we're thinking about it make it's just
like you're like respectful it's like I
love you as a friend but I also think
it's her hug experience and your
confidence because I've heard from many
girls that when David hugs them none of
them feel any creepy vibes he just has
this warm embrace sounds a lot oh man I
[ __ ] love you as a sister and I think
if you have a lot of hug experiences
it's like the touching the physical
touch comes natural
you know like for a lot of us I feel
like it wasn't like that like in our
childhood for me it's know wasn't there
I think physical touch is natural I
think when it's not there that there's
something unnatural
you know like babies I grew up without
with that the skin-to-skin contact they
end up being like so super whoa that's
extreme but yeah yeah totally
which is exactly why I like right I've
never had a child but you know I see you
know mothers and fathers newborns
they're just putting them on
skin-to-skin and it's a very natural
thing to feel that you know in the need
that so I don't know about the sociopath
thing but there was a Russian orphanage
I think I pencil that where's orphanage
that that had that date they did this
study because they didn't have enough
like what do you call it those those
nursers to hold the babies mm-hmm so
they did a longitudinal study to see
where they would go and a lot of them
ended up killers being single and not
needing anyone and not understanding the
the like questions yeah like they don't
need it they were all parts well part is
actually needs it like he actually wants
it so but not actually part but no no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know he's got
jujitsu but there are people out there
that don't need it or don't connect to
it or don't communicate with it because
they there's a phase within the first
five years that if you don't program
that within the first five it's so
that's why I'm like is it really human
nature or not because if you don't
program that within the first five years
then you don't communicate that way well
that's what she's saying the article
it's a rebellious for men it's it is
program it is an environmental thing for
women it comes hereditary 45% I wonder
where they got that percentage but then
woman hug yeah that um so like once you
become a mother this is what my cousin
says she's like and the kids grow up you
start to extremely like Miss hugging and
cuddly
because you're constantly holding a life
yeah it was like that so Isaac hasn't
laid on my chest since he was like six
years old seven years old and then
recently we were just hugging and I was
like like I didn't realize I missed it
so much cuz he had always been like you
would always sleep on my chest when he
was a baby and then now he's 12 and we
were just hugging and I'm like oh my god
I really like it made me realize how we
don't touch as much as what did he say
are you gonna make by Zeke now Isaac
she's like why'd you name me this